boy oh boy do we have a myth for you
where do you get a load of this one
we're gonna see if we can blow up a
tornado the filled with sharks eight
sharknado if you will
I'm Way too silver for this so why don't
I take a shot when we cut to a random
hot chick and her team
well whatever we're working on is never
as impressive as what you're working on
so let's get back to you that's better
so Jamie what do we learn today that if
two people can survive a tornado
strapped through a drainage pipe leather
belts anything is possible
so once again this hour of your life was
a waste of time why aren't you watching
storage wars Amy
hey Jamie a lot of people have been
wondering is it possible to set water on
fire
who the hell is wondering that let's
check in with a random hot chick um I
have a pH do you know whatever just say
some puns now we're really in hot water
I'm gonna go kill myself in my trailer